- I'm Jeff Goldblum and
these are thirst tweets.
(upbeat music)
You, oh my god, Chris Hemsworth is so hot.
Me, being intellectual, I would
let Jeff Goldblum murder me.
Murder, of course, being...
That's the poetical way of
saying you kill me, baby,
you kill me, baby.
I would let Jeff Goldblum
(laughter)
redacted my redacted.
You have to fill in your own redactions.
I'm thinking of something.
I would let Jeff Goldblum...
Wow, geez.
I would let Jeff Goldblum
rearrange my guts any day.
That man exudes sexy and expensive.
(laughter)
I exude sexy and expensive.
What the heck's that mean?
Any affection that I come
to exchange has never been
for recompense.
I'd be remiss if I didn't tell you that.
It says no offense, in capitals,
but I would pay millions of
dollars to have Jeff
Goldblum sit on my face
exactly like this.
Exactly like that.
I'd be like this, I'd
be like this, you know.
Things I want in a man.
Six foot four, that's exactly
my height, libra, Jewish,
you want a Jewish man,
oscar nominated actor, yes,
I was nominated.
Oh, and is Jeff Goldblum.
Oh, that's me, so it is me.
So that's what she wants in a man.
That's sweet.
It's a lovely thing to be
appreciated in any way.
Jeff Goldblum's voice
could wake me from a coma.
Mal, come back to us, Mal.
Mal?
She's back!
Jeff Goldblud always looks
like he'd listen deeply to your
sorrows and let you have his
most expensive bottle of wine
to make you feel better.
The word daddy was made to
be used on Jeff Goldblum
and him alone.
Don't at me?
What's that mean?
- [Cameraman] If you at someone--
&- Yes?
- --you're calling them out.
- Oh, don't at me, don't at me.
Okay, I accept it, I accept it.
Why is Jeff Goldblum so attractive?
He's 30 or so years older
than me and I'm a lesbian
but he gets me hot and bothered.
Bothered is trademarked.
(laughter)
Why is bothered trademarked?
Sitting in the back of this
Uber on the 134 thinking about
my sexual awakening, AKA
Jeff Goldblum wearing those
leather pants in Jurassic Park.
You like leather clothing?
Eh, sure.
I don't know you well enough, nevermind.
(laughter)
God, I want Jeff Goldblum to
stroke my hand and talk about
microscopic variations in
the skin, like he did with
Laura Dern's character in Jurassic Park.
Oh, and look at the tiny
hairs in your hands.
Imperfections, imperfections?
Not, nothing, not that way, imperfections.
Look at that, look at that.
That was the most fun I
ever had in my whole life.
I mean, golly.
Very, very flattering.
(bright ukulele music)
(squeak)